por qué
[Música]
a sus 60 años y debido a un paro
cardiorrespiratorio falleció el astro
del fútbol argentino diego armando
maradona considerado por la fifa como el
jugador del siglo y uno de los más
destacados exponentes de este deporte a
nivel mundial argentina y el mundo del
deporte lloran su partida tenemos
reporte desde la ciudad de buenos aires
la noticia de la muerte del futbolista
argentino diego armando maradona
rápidamente le dio la vuelta al mundo
desde jefes de estado y de gobierno
deportistas artistas líderes de opinión
y personalidades ha lamentado su
fallecimiento tenemos algunas de las
redacciones
y miles de mujeres se tomaron las calles
de varias ciudades de américa latina
para conmemorar el día internacional de
la eliminación de la violencia contra
las mujeres más de 4600 mujeres fueron
asesinadas en américa latina' en el año
2019 y una de cada tres de ellas en el
mundo ha padecido algún tipo de
violencia en su vida
muy buenas noches gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález bienvenidos a esta
actualización de noticias el mundo
entero le dice adiós al astro del fútbol
argentino diego armando maradona quien
falleció a los 60 años en su casa en el
norte de la ciudad de buenos aires en
donde se estaba recuperando después de
haber sido sometido a una cirugía por un
edema craneal el pasado 11 de noviembre
si bien todavía estamos a la espera de
los resultados de la autopsia oficial
los primeros indicios apuntan a que
maradona habría fallecido debido a un
paro cardiorrespiratorio desde el
gobierno argentino decretaron tres días
de duelo nacional y su cuerpo será
velado en la casa rosada- que es la casa
sede del gobierno federal argentino
vamos a conocer más detalles de esta
noticia que enluta al mundo del deporte
vamos hasta buenos aires allí en la
capital argentina está nuestro
corresponsal natalio con soy natalio muy
buenas noches allí en argentina y cuáles
son las reacciones allí en este país sea
cuna del astro del fútbol diego armando
maradona y que se espera por parte de
los ciudadanos para las próximas horas
le pregunto
ya hay grandes concentraciones de
ciudadanos en puntos estratégicos como
el obelisco de buenos aires
[Música]
hola que tal buenas noches empecemos por
contar que por supuesto todas las
figuras públicas de la argentina la de
la política del espectáculo y por
supuesto del deporte y del mundo
salieron a manifestar su pesar por la
muerte de diego armando maradona y como
bien señalaba en muchos puntos de
argentina específicamente de la ciudad
de buenos aires- se están viendo
concentraciones como esta en la puerta
del estadio de boca juniors el club
no fue si se quiere el primer lugar
donde jugó diego armando maradona el
otro club donde está concentrando gente
de argentinos suyos donde comenzó su
carrera pero sin duda su gran amor
futbolístico fue boca y boca siempre ha
querido llamado a diego armando maradona
y están así celebrando con gritos con
aplausos con tantos vistiendo la
camiseta de boca vistiendo la camiseta
de argentina la figura de diego armando
maradona es una combinación de pesar de
tristeza y de emoción por lo que
representa la figura de maradona lo
mismo se ve aquí en el estadio de
argentinos juniors que lleva el nombre
de diego armando maradona y también en
el obelisco en el centro de la capital
argentina así se van despidiendo
empezando a despedirse los seguidores
los amantes de la figura de maradona
esto continuará el día jueves a las 8 de
la mañana aproximadamente con
la de la despedida el velorio que tendrá
lugar en la casa rosada- la casa de
gobierno de la argentina el gobierno
puso a disposición de la familia y de
todos los seguidores de maradona este
espacio público para la despedida del
astro futbolístico argentino a partir de
ahí veremos todavía no sabemos bien cómo
va a seguir cuáles van a ser los
siguientes pasos dónde será enterrado
diego armando maradona estamos esperando
la confirmación de cómo se irá este
devenir pero ciertamente las despedidas
no se terminan ni hoy ni el jueves esto
continuará varios días gracias a natalio
por este reporte desde la ciudad de
buenos aires- concentraciones
espontáneas de seguidores de ciudadanos
argentinos que quieren rendir tributo a
diego armando maradona rápidamente esta
noticia de la muerte del futbolista
argentino comenzó a ser comentada en
redes sociales y también en varios
medios de comunicación por
personalidades internacionales de todo
tipo desde jefes de estado- jefes de
gobierno deportistas artistas líderes de
opinión expresaron sus condolencias al
pueblo argentino al fútbol internacional
y sobre todo a la familia
de diego maradona desde nápoles donde
jugó siete años hasta buenos aires- el
mundo despidió al astro del fútbol así
veamos
luto en buenos aires y en nápoles la
muerte de diego armando maradona el
número 10 del fútbol argentino
estremeció al mundo la liga es de verdad
una noticia trágica en un año pésimo
parado un enano
maradona es nápoles el amor de nápoles y
de los napolitanos por diego será eterno
murió a sus 60 años por causa de un paro
cardiorrespiratorio deja atrás una vida
de hazañas derrotas y controversias el
'pelusa' como era conocido es símbolo de
renombre en argentina nos lleva hasta lo
más alto del mundo nos hiciste
inmensamente felices fuiste el más
grande de todos gracias por haber
existido diego te vamos a extrañar toda
la vida un día muy triste para todos los
argentinos y para el fútbol nos deja
pero no se va porque el diego es eterno
un mensaje de eternidad que se escuchó
también aquí en el barrio la boca de
buenos aires- de cientos de seguidores
le rinden homenaje al astro
lo venía viendo uno
pero nunca qué
lejos de su familia maradona es parte
del orgullo deportivo e histórico
argentino nacido en lanús una localidad
al sur de la capital porteña siempre
indicó que a diferencia del libertador
en general josé sanmartín el quería
morir en argentina y hoy lo cumplió
esta noche a las siete y cuarto de la
noche hora de bogotá a nueve y cuarto de
la noche hora de buenos aires france 24
les presentará un programa especial bajo
la conducción de juan pupiales y luís
méndez con motivo del fallecimiento del
futbolista argentino diego armando
maradona no se lo pierdan
y vamos a cambiar de tema américa latina
se convirtió en el foco de las marchas
conmemorativas del día internacional de
la eliminación de la violencia contra
las mujeres precisamente es esta región
una de las en las que más cantidad de
casos de violencia se están registrando
en el mundo una de cada tres mujeres ha
padecido violencia a lo largo de su vida
mientras que en 2019 los feminicidios
superaron los 4600 según el observatorio
de igualdad de género de américa latina
y el caribe una cifra que podría
empeorar en el 2020 ya que la violencia
ha aumentado durante los meses de
confinamiento por la pandemia miles de
manifestaciones tanto en las principales
capitales como en otras ciudades han
servido para movilizar a ciudadanos en
rechazo a la discriminación de género
exigir leyes contra los crímenes
machistas y mostrar su respaldo a la
despenalización de la interrupción del
embarazo incluso las medidas contra la
pandemia no impidieron que miles de
ciudadanos salieran a las calles para
exigir sus demandas y reivindicar la
igualdad de la mujer vamos a conocer
cómo transcurrió la jornada en la ciudad
de lima la capital de perú allí está
francisco zacarías francisco
buenas noches allí en lima y en el caso
de perú cuáles son las exigencias que
tienen allí las mujeres y han salido a
las calles a reivindicar las y también
cómo es el panorama en perú en general
en términos de cifras
buenas noches las mujeres exigen
justicia para las víctimas de violencia
sexual y feminicidio también una nueva
constitución que priorice la igualdad de
género el respeto a los derechos humanos
de todas las mujeres también pide acceso
mixto a la política libre de acoso ellas
se están demandando entre otras cosas
participación y de que sea una educación
sexual integral para que nadie padezca
embarazos ni maternidad de forzadas
asimismo piden que se haya una reforma
policial para que las mujeres no sufran
el acoso sexual por parte de algunos
policías durante las jornadas de
protesta podemos decir que la violencia
contra la mujer se ha convertido en perú
como una nueva pandemia en la defensoría
del pueblo ha detallado que en lo que va
de enero a octubre de este año
4500 mujeres niñas y adolescentes han
sido registradas como desaparecidas en
paralelo el ministerio de la mujer y
poblaciones vulnerables ha señalado que
a la fecha se han registrado 101
feminicidios 234 tentativas de
feminicidios y 6 mil 893 casos de
violencia sexual es por eso que
diferentes organizaciones le piden a las
autoridades peruanas medidas urgentes de
solución con justicia y equidad gracias
a francisco por este reporte desde la
ciudad del ivam vale la pena decir que
en las próximas emisiones de las
noticias de france 24 vamos a estar
llevando el reporte de otras ciudades de
américa latina en donde también hubo
marchas similares por ejemplo en mexico
y en bogotá por el momento nos
despedimos les recuerdo a las siete y
cuarto de la noche hora de bogotá al
especial en torno al fallecimiento del
deportista argentino diego armando
maradona ustedes pueden seguir con estas
y otras noticias en france 24 punto com
en las redes sociales y también en la
app siga con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]